[Musique]
en sport à tous alors la discussion
philosophique avec les enfants mais pas
qu'eux avec les enfants vous allez voir
pg vous voyez que j'ai nommé cette
présentation la discussion philosophique
outil de formation parce que je pense
qu'on peut le mener des discussions
philosophiques avec les enfants c'est
sûrement plus paradoxal puisque réservez
déjà en cumul mais donc c'est un petit
pas paradoxal de mal avec les enfants
c'est pour ça que c'est accroché
sûrement n'est pas passé inaperçu auprès
dun certain nombre de personnes voit que
se développe progressivement des grands
noms des années mais je pense maintenant
de plus en plus parce qu'on me le
demande aussi que la discussion ne pas
être mené dans d'autres pays et pas
seulement avec des enfants voudraient
commencer cette intervention par deux
citations écouter les conférences le
crioc une précède la première citation
c'est toute philosophie est
autobiographique et auto justificatrice
a bien évidemment tout ce que nous avons
entendu c'est à présent semble démontrer
la justesse cette citation est bien
évidemment ce que je vais vous dire
aujourd'hui ne déroge pas à cette règle
7 cette phrase que je met en exergue
elle n'est pas de moi elle est de notre
ami frédéric nietzsche ou x pour yves
hermann nitsch ni churn après faune et
elle été remise au goût du jour par
notre ami michel onfray corps lâche
présentes au moment de manger d'autres
avis parce que je le connais
personnellement puisque je suis de camp
et que quand j'ai commencé à animer des
moments de discussion philosophique je
vais chercher forcément des et
philosophe de renom qui seraient
susceptibles de disputer avec moi avoir
deux
de parler de ces pratiques là qui
étaient complètement inconnus à cette
époque là c'est dans la deuxième moitié
des années 90 beaucoup d'entre vous
n'étaient pas les mêmes
et donc je vais j'ai contacté bernard
warain quelques autres on n'a aucune
réponse sauf de sylviane agacinski
tenter quelque chose du même genre
sympathique et un jour je découvre donc
que michel onfray s'intéressent déjà à
ces pratiques là et qu'en plus il habite
la même vie que moi et du coup on est
devenus proches voire amis et une
deuxième citation l'homme est la mesure
de toute chose qui s'inscrit en faux par
rapport à ce que platon pouvait dire
inquiets eux il y avait un juste un vrai
un beau en soi et que chacun devait
tenter d'y accéder par l'intermédiaire
d'un philosophe
pourquoi pas d'un philosophe roi et ses
protagoras pape terre impro grand
emprunt de platon avec l'antiquité mais
qui sait partie de l'udc des saucisses
mon parcours très rapidement parce que
te fais de ton mieux oravig moment entre
non plus j'étais instituteur sur le
petit programme que vous avez rendu
confusion dans les dates
en fait j'étais resté en 40 ans de 2007
à 2015 mais en fait comme j'étais
l'ancienne génération entrée à l'école
normale à l'âge de
le 18 tentés de nasser de 10 places
avait 18 ans ce kit est une pop font
savoir en quelle année je suis né il ya
des toiles et ensuite après avoir été
donc qui ensuite c'était une continuité
parce que je suis toujours intéressé
dans mon parcours d'instituteur à des
dispositifs pédagogiques qui permettait
aux enfants de discuter entre eux et de
discuter comment souvent de discuter de
quoi très tôt et commencer c'est un plat
en consommer en herbe ou à la vie qu'on
garde la disposition habituelle de la
place un problème parce que ans r c'est
difficile dans les classes ans ils ont
en rectangle sur pratiquement et les
questions sur le même côté que discuter
de quoi souvent les dispositifs
pédagogiques que j'ai utilisées et
d'albert titus ionel pour ceux qui
connaissent on parle des événements
grâce au programme de ce qu'on peut
mettre en place pour que ça se déroule
mieux de travail gestion des conflits et
puis un jour donc en 1998 après un temps
de pratique en classe évidement je
découvre un stage d'initiation à la
philosophie pour les enfants j'ai
présenté la démarche lippmann matthews
band ou important à retenir philosophe
pragmatiste nord-américain la région de
boston qui était le premier à dire mes
élèves professeurs de technologie malins
ceux qui ne suivent pas mes élèves donc
ont des lacunes en philo comment faire
pour qu'ils en aient un peu moins
d'élèves qu'il avait eu à l'âge
là les études de philo c'est à dire à
partir du 18 ans à 18 ans eh bien on va
commencer plus tôt ben franchement
plutôt terre à trois ans dès
l'apparition du langage en 2002 fort de
cette expérience que j'ai mise en
pratique très digne j'ai participé à la
création de l'université populaire de
ban avec rania montrait donc cette ligne
de sony de ces initiatives qu'il a
quitté l'enseignement ou des
probiotiques et c'est du je vends pour
enseigner n'est plus sous le regard de
l'institution il a donc créé cette
université populaire qui est
universitaire him is you ve hayat
exigèrent après regarde de délivrer à la
sortie et c'est gratuit
bien évidemment il m'a dit tout est
restée anonyme dans la troupe des gens
qui viendraient assistèrent à neubourg
pourquoi ne venez-vous pas mettre en
place à un atelier de discussion
philosophique avec les enfants que j'ai
accepté il m'a obligé ensuite écrire un
livre qu'il a gentiment préfacé il
s'appelle la raison ce faire il s'est
d'abord là du tout mais le leinster a
fait faillite l'année suivie alors n'y
voyez pas nécessairement un rapport de
cause à effet ou pas et en ce moment je
suis en train de rédiger nouvelle
mouture de ce même livre qui tient
compte de l'évolution de mon parcours
depuis cette époque là parce que d'aller
voir dans la suite que la façon de
concevoir les ateliers de discussion
philosophie n'est pas figé et qu'elle
est évolutive un bref historique de ces
démarches parce que bien sûr c'est pas
une fois j'ai inventé sommes donc on a
d'abord eu les travaux de newman qui
dose of dirt américains pour des années
70 et puis en 1998 il a fallu un petit
moment commun pour que les autorités
seront se passe quelque chose
d'intéressant là dans ces moments de
discussion des enfants l'unesco réunit
un comité d'experts qui s'intéresse
exclusivement à ce moment là la démarche
whitman qui est la seule vraiment connu
alors que d'autres
énergie et ce rapport d'expert contient
cette citation que je ne plais à redire
parce que les enjeux de la diffuse deux
filles avec les enfants et avec d'autres
personnes sont entièrement contenue dans
cette citation je vous la vie donc au
delà d'une participation d'autres
médiatique avec nouvelle vague d'intérêt
de la philosophie pour les enfants
rentrent dans les préoccupations
fondamentales de 1000 euros en vue d'une
promotion d'une culture de la paix de
buts entre la violence
le fait que les enfants acquièrent très
jeunes l'esprit critique m l'autonomie à
la réflexion et le jugement par eux
mêmes les assurent contre la
manipulation de tous ordres et les
prépare à prendre en main leur propre
destin en 2003 grâce à l'université
populaire de caen nous participons
michel leeb deux amis deux offres et moi
de laventure à une table ronde organisée
par l'unesco de la philosophie populaire
on sent une influence de denis diderot
le philosophe français les lumières qui
avait dit à ton nous de rendre la
philosophie populaire en 2004 l'unesco
toujours demande d'animer une table
ronde cette fois sur l'aspect ce dossier
avec les ensembles dossier les premiers
colloques
ce colloque qui réunissait tout à tous
ces praticiens chercheurs c'est évident
la deuxième moitié des années 90 en
france à pratiquer la philosophie avec
les enfants avec différentes méthodes
ce colloque était itinérant depuis les
années le début des années 2 nous est
accueilli à l'unesco
donc ce premier colloque est accueilli à
vinexpo le jour de novembre
un jeudi de novembre que vous n'arrivez
beaujolais nouveau ça n'a rien à voir
hall d'expo fait au niveau international
niveau planétaire
la philosophie est bien ce prologue est
accueilli pour la première fois en 2006
a vu des sports et idylis tient toujours
présents régulièrement et enfin en 2015
il faut savoir dans les instructions
officielles de l'école en france on
parle pour la première fois de
discussions thématiques dans le domaine
de l'eau cm éducation civique de morale
c'est à dire que tous les enfants de
ans et n'a pas à l'école élémentaire et
au collège devrait rencontrer de façon
régulière des moments où on leur propose
de dix prix philosophiquement de
différencier c'est dans les instructions
officielles juin 2015
pas très vieux et en 2015 encore en
septembre a mené ce qu une exposé d'un
site un rôle considérable dans la
promotion de ces pratiques à l'unesco et
créer une chaire de philosophie pour
enfants qui s'appelle la pratique de la
philosophie avec les enfants une base
pour le dialogue interculturel et la
transformation sociale
l'énumération visia on a eu en novembre
2007 des toutes récentes
j'assiste sur la transformation sociale
une façon de boucler la boucle
matthew newman disait il nous faut
philosopher avec les enfants dans le but
dans l'espoir de générer des changements
sociaux
quel intérêt les bombes d'hier tous les
enfants nous semble-t-il à nouveau
l'université populaire demande de quelle
philosophie que nous représentons tous
les enfants naissent philosophe
seuls certains le donneur ça signifie
que ceux chez qui on n'entretient pas
diva cette flamme de questionnement
philosophique on risque de tout chez eux
le philosophe dans l'oeuf grosse
responsabilité de tous les éducateurs
cette personne entendons nous bien
lorsque ce discours peut être facilement
entendu comme un discours mobilisateur
pour les éducateurs privés publics une
prise de conscience simplement les
enfants en cette potentialité en eux
essayons de réfléchir pour voir comment
on peut maintenir diva cette femme c'est
une phrase de michel onfray
il s'agit donc de maintenir 10 cette
flamme
ça peut aller à l'école c'est peut être
fait dans l'immédiat texte c'est donc
dans les amis ça peut être long et
centres culturels dans un endroit
différent
il s'agit de maintenir de former dans
l'avenir dit face la famille justement
pour former des individus autonomes
c'est à dire capable de se réjouir
parleurs les droits qu'ils se donnent
d'eux-mêmes
c'est le b team au dessus du mont cotton
comme je bâtis moi même les lois qui le
régissent
bien évidemment pas de connotation se
durcissent tu ne s'agit pas de bâtir son
propre
moral puisque on discute en groupe ça
veut dire que les normes les lois que je
me donne ne buzze compte revenir à celle
que c'est un processus de discussion
donc qui est essentiellement
démocratique
je vous rappelle que la naissance de la
démocratie sané - le vote
c'est la discussion donc former des
individus autonomes apte à prendre en
main leur destin
béatrice fonds pour le rendre meilleur
on retrouve exactement la situation dans
la citation de nice pau et bénéfice
collatéral n'est pas que pas que
collatéral
il s'agit de développer les habiletés
langagières donc les habilités de penser
si on n'a pas des mots pensée l'abstrait
pour penser la généralité pour penser et
concepts sur un parle de liberté si on
n'a pas le mot amour si on n'a pas
atteint
enfin tous les grands mots vous
connaissez qu'ils peuvent vous venir à
l'esprit nous fait penser maintenant
comment procéder il faut savoir que les
démarches sont diverses qui faisait
parler à plusieurs reprises je parle moi
je vous ai parlé à plusieurs reprises de
la démarche de matthew key man sommes
maintenant une voie en 2010
une démarche assez particulier à passer
sur des romans que l'immeuble avait
écrit ce qui signifiait pour moi c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles j'ai
abandonné cette démarche
ce qui signifiait que puisqu'on parle à
chaque fois dans chaque moment d'une
discussion d'un livre on le risque de
extrait de livre un roman en france on
risque de développer chez les enfants et
chez les participants aux ateliers de
vice champion l'idée qu' il n'est de
philosophie que si on est en présence
d'un livre et d'un adulte
estampillée chez les hommes moi je prend
le contre-pied inverse
je prends cette cette posture à
contre-pied absolument parce que je
pense que nous sommes tous philosophes
et que la vérité va bien ce chiffre n
est pas d'emblée inégalée dans l'oeuf
mon choix moi et donc de ne pas
nécessairement
partir la livre d'éviter ce procès
systématique de la démarche
hillman les initier un dialogue
socratique libertaire donc comment je
procède je demande simplement aux
participants qu'ils trouvent chacun un
mot fort
très vite les enfants comprennent qu'il
faut mieux de dire à moore qui est
travail
liberté égalité que la blood trottoir en
part que michel durand et d'autres si
qu' il n'y a pas de questions proprement
philosophique il n'y a que des
traitements antibiotiques de toutes les
questions possibles on peut interroger
fils ont fait pas la démonstration ici
mais pourra faire un groupe de travail
pour tous chacun trouve un mot fort à
partir de ces baux pour une fois qu'on
prend très vite les enfants compagnie
les enfants comprennent il s'agit de
mots tels que j'ai voté ont bâti des
questions à partir de ces mots donc à
partir du mot bord par exemple on va
plus pour bâtir une question à dix et
universel en évitant les mon propre ça
c'est le conseil que je donne ou les
pronoms de jeu tu es vous avec attention
à partir du moment où on m'a pris pour
poser la question pourquoi veulent tant
que commandant les 4 et 10 morts l'inde
est l'une de ces questions est choisi au
moyen d'un vote
et cette question qui est choisie
devient d'une certaine façon
l'expression de l'inconscient collectif
du groupe réunira ce moment-là toute
philosophie et de dominos graphique
aussi moi j'aime ça porte la question
elle sera sûrement autobiographique pour
moi mais rien ne garantit pas pour vous
et ensuite
s'instaure un moment de discussion qui
est démocratique et libertaire
initiateurs vise sa disparition idéal
c'est que à un moment donné sortir de la
pièce faire ce que je veux revenir et on
se devait arriver 0
c'est passé pro glacial monde à
continuer comme ça parce que nous
voulons c'est que les enfants devaient
autonome autonome et qu'il n'est plus
besoin de quelqu'un leur dise maintenant
c'est de la philo et toute discussion
est suivie d'un moment de bilan
et c'est grâce à ces bilans que petit à
petit dans les groupes que je venais en
place et à l'université populaire de
caen j'ai pu abandonner le texte une
manne qui nous est apparu est apparu
pour disputant aux enfants qu'elle a
finalement un petit peu superflu dans la
mesure où on pouvait tout à fait ont-ils
proposé un jour blanc on pouvait tout à
fait proposer une question qu'elle était
issue des séances passées dans beaucoup
de portes musique et donc c'est comme ça
que petit à petit mais d'un dispositif
productif remis entre les mains des
enfants
aulas prend petit à petit j'en suis
arrivé à la démarche de deux semaines
actuellement qui est donc libertaire
puisqu'on pas des idées des enfants mais
qui peut aussi à d'autres moments
s'exercer sur des oeuvres d'art soient
développement des événements d'actualité
parmi ses oeuvres d'art bien évidemment
d heure de la fin
j'aimerais qu'on pense à généraliser
donc ces pratiques là on peut pratiquer
à l'époque et dans d'autres lieux de
culture des médias ted déferrage déjà
dit viser d'autres publient lancé
récemment une série d'ateliers de
discussion fixe aux tic dans un centre
de détention où se livrent les deux
questions qui m'ont été proposées sur ce
modèle pendant les deux dernières
séances de première qui sommes nous pour
juger la la violence couvert de tels le
monde quand je dis que tous les risques
et existentielle on peut donc aussi
discuté philosophiquement en communauté
hétérogènes en âge des enfants des
adolescents et des adultes
ça peut se pratiquer je les fais et
employés les habiletés développer dans
toutes les situations fasse pas
n'importe quel support une banque lui
sur provisoire voyez comme sommes dans
une posture défend à une pratique de la
fusée
différentes on dit actuellement en
terminale dans les salles des silos ou
la laisse la part des gens s'imaginent
que la philosophie consiste à discuter
d'une chair est ferme et dix courts sur
des textes
socrates ne faisait pas disposer des
gradins pour les auditeurs il fut le
premier à montrer que en tout temps dans
tout endroit dans tout ce qui nous
arrive est bon puisque nous faisons la
vie quotidienne on donne la possibilité
de philosopher on sait que ça résume
assez bien tout ce que j'ai besoin
aujourd'hui ce sera ce n'est pas de moi
et des plus tarp
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]